It is certainly not unheard of for a young
girl to wake up in the middle of the night,
looking for a glass of water.
It is somewhat more exceptional when this
late-night water run results in many, many
deaths.
Unless, of course, you’re dealing with a
very special Young Girl - SCP-053, also known
as...
Well, the Young Girl.
She possesses the innate ability to inspire
delusions, paranoia, and eventually homicidal
rage in anyone who spends too long around
her.
Which, as you can probably imagine, makes
it hard to live a normal life.
One night, the Young Girl woke up to something
incredibly strange.
The door of her cell, typically tightly sealed,
was wide open - and a strange, flashing red
light was shining in through the hallway.
The sound of a distant alarm is what had woken
her up.
What the Young Girl didn’t know was that
the site confining her had just experienced
a mass containment breach, as a result of
a major electrical malfunction.
Some of the most terrifying creatures imaginable
were roaming the halls in search of violence
and carnage.
But when the Young Girl got up and wandered
out of her bedroom, she only wanted a glass
of water, to quench her midnight thirst.
She wandered down a long, plain hallway, washed
intermittently in red by the flashing emergency
lights.
She rubbed the sleep out of her eyes and yawned.
All this strange commotion, maybe she’s
just having a bad dream.
But what seems like a bad dream to her is
a bonafide living nightmare for everyone around
her: A few halls over, security personnel
were being devoured alive by SCP-682.
SCP-106, the Old Man, had just dragged a senior
researcher into his pocket dimension to do
unspeakable things to him.
And a group of terrified admin staff are being
lured out by what they think is a group of
Mobile Task Force Operatives, but is actually
a pack of hungry SCP-939 imitating their voices.
Still, the Young Girl persisted in her quest
for a refreshing drink, even as security personnel
began to fan out through the building, hoping
to get control over this rapidly devolving
situation.
A group of five armed security officers ran
into the hallway and attempted to intercept
the Young Girl, but the high stress they were
already feeling only accelerated the effects
of the Young Girl’s anomalous powers.
They started to feel bugs crawling all over
their skin.
They started to get the sense that their fellow
security officers weren’t even people, but
monsters wearing human skin suits.
Their paranoia soon evolved into a blistering
rage.
Each of the men pulled out their guns and
began firing at each other until only one
was left standing - Wounded, but alive.
With all the others dead, the object of his
rage now became the Young Girl herself.
He understood then that it was all her doing,
that she’d made him do this.
She was a monstrous little creature who took
pleasure in twisting the minds of human beings
into terrible forms.
In reality, the Young Girl had no such feelings.
Her powers were passive, she had no control
over them.
She even suffered from some kind of strange
mental block that left her completely unaware
that her powers were even taking effect.
She was, in a sense, completely innocent.
As the security officer pointed his gun at
the Young Girl as she began walking into a
nearby break room, he experienced her secondary
anomalous effect.
Anyone who attempts to hurt her will immediately
die from either a heart attack or a stroke.
The security officer suddenly felt an intense
pain, sharp and brutal, exploding in his chest.
He collapsed, dead before he even hit the
ground, and the Young Girl had no idea.
She couldn’t if she tried.
In the break room, the Young Girl found exactly
what she was looking for: A classic office
water cooler, complete with a stack of plastic
cups.
Perfect.
She carefully took one of the cups and pulled
down the lever on the cooler, watching her
cup fill as the tank above the cooler bubbled.
She took a sip.
Cool, refreshing spring water.
Just what the doctor ordered.
But the Young Girl suddenly looked up, shocked,
to see that the tank above the water cooler
was now shaking violently, as though it was
going to explode.
What was going on here?
Had she broken it?
She stepped back, dropping the rest of her
cup of water to the ground.
She felt frightened.
That’s when a crack formed in the plastic
tank, and the water began slithering out.
Not dripping or pouring, slithering, as though
it moved with mind and purpose.
And that’s because, in this case, it did.
The Young Girl hadn’t just drank any water,
she’d drunk half a cup of water from SCP-054,
the Water Nymph: A mysterious, sentient woman
made entirely from water.
Much like the Young Girl, the Water Nymph
is an often misunderstood anomaly.
One that has received far more harm from the
cruel treatment of the SCP Foundation than
she’s ever given to another.
She’s a naturally curious and compassionate
creature, whose trust has been abused.
So, when the containment breach alarms started
to sound, much like the rest of Foundation
staff, she had tried to hide and find cover,
not wanting to fall into the crosshairs of
a far more dangerous and hostile anomaly.
She’d chosen the water cooler in break room
3 - which seemed like a genius idea, until
the Young Girl turned up.
After years of being experimented on by Foundation
researchers, the Water Nymph wasn’t about
to tolerate more mistreatment.
Whatever this strange little creature was
who’d just consumed some of her body, the
Water Nymph would fight back, and make it
regret ever thinking it could take advantage
of her.
The Young Girl - Who really had just made
an innocent mistake - began to panic and run
as a frightening, slithering tendril of pure
water came slithering after her.
As the unfortunate security guard discovered
earlier, trying to attack the Young Girl was
typically a one-way ticket to a heart attack
or fatal cerebral event.
But seeing as the Water Nymph had neither
a heart nor a brain, she was invulnerable,
and the Young Girl was terrified.
She ran out of the room, past the bodies of
the several men who’d killed each other
due to her influence outside.
She wasn’t even able to notice them - She
kept running, and the water of the Water Nymph
came slithering after her.
The Water Nymph had never been the vengeful
type, but after the abuse she’d suffered,
she learned the value of putting her liquid
foot down.
She would not tolerate mistreatment, even
from a being this small.
The Young Girl kept running, breathing heavily.
Because of the nature of her anomalous abilities,
nobody could intervene and help her.
Occasionally, she’d run into groups of Foundation
personnel trying to fight their way through
the chaos - only to be anomalously affected
and become a part of the chaos themselves.
They became violent, deranged monsters and
started attacking each other, punching and
biting.
As they fell to the ground in a brawling pile,
the Young Girl had to desperately climb over
them as the streak of furious liquid followed
her.
Meanwhile, across the facility, the vicious,
psychopathic old man was hungry for more.
His mouth stretched into a wide, sadistic
grin, and he continued walking further into
the base.
He would find new victims.
He would feel their fear and drink in their
dying screams.
Several Mobile Task Forces were dispatched
from other nearby containment facilities.
They’d likely reach the embattled site within
the hour, but how many lives would be lost
before then?
The death count was already well into the
double digits.
After all this running, the Young Girl was
getting tired.
It was rare that she needed to truly avoid
and escape a threat like this, and as such,
she wasn’t exactly prepared for such a scenario.
She found her way to a broom closet and locked
herself inside, hiding among mops and brooms.
She tried to quiet her breathing, holding
a tiny hand over her mouth.
Red flashes continued to occasionally illuminate
the corners of the door.
She breathed in, and out.
In, and out.
Was something waiting outside?
The Young Girl gasped as water started bubbling
underneath the door.
It started looking around her feet, then rising
up from the ground.
To the Young Girl, it was astonishing.
The water was forming the shape of a woman,
standing right in front of her.
Her lower lip trembled with fear.
For a moment, she was lost for words.
Then she gulped dryly, and began to speak
in a soft, little voice.
“I’m so sorry, I didn’t mean to hurt
you, I promise!
I was just thirsty!”
The Water Nymph tilted her head slightly,
confused.
Did this tiny child really mean this?
Was it an honest mistake?
After all the terrible things that had been
done to her, the Water Nymph had difficulty
trusting humans.
But as the Young Girl started to cry, for
reasons she couldn’t quite understand, the
Water Nymph felt the urge to comfort her.
Perhaps she wasn’t with the Foundation;
perhaps this girl was just another prisoner.
They were allies, not enemies.
While the Water Nymph couldn’t speak, as
a show of solidarity, she began to transform.
She got smaller, herself becoming a little
girl made of water, almost mirroring SCP-053.
She raised a hand and waved.
The Young Girl giggled, seemingly put at ease.
It’d been a long time since she met a new
friend around here, and it seemed like the
Water Nymph was ready to change that.
Maybe they could escape this place together.
The Young Girl opened the door, and the two
of them ran out together, passing through
an adjacent hallway.
The Young Girl ran while the Water Nymph slithered
formlessly along behind her.
They managed to sneak around and avoid detection
from the many anomalies and Foundation guards
duking it out for supremacy in the chaotic
halls of the facility.
In a sense, it provided the perfect cover
for the unlikely duo to escape this bizarre
situation.
But they weren’t out of the metaphorical
woods yet.
First, they were cornered by a trio of paranoid
guards, all wielding handguns.
However, the Young Girl’s nightmarish ambient
ability came in handy once more.
The three men lost their minds and started
killing each other, giving the Young Girl
and the Water Nymph more time to escape and
keep moving.
Though they were about to encounter the deadliest
threat of all.
The Young Girl took point, leading the Water
Nymph down the nearest hallway, when suddenly,
SCP-106, the Old Man, emerged from the wall
right in front of her.
He had such anomalous malice in him that the
Young Girl’s power was effectively useless
against him.
He grinned and approached her, his arms extended,
ready to ferry her off to the nightmare of
his pocket dimension.
The Young Girl had never felt so afraid.
Until suddenly, the Water Nymph slithered
in between them, and she assumed her full
humanoid form once more, forming a wall between
the Young Girl and the Old Man.
This turned out to be the perfect way to save
the Young Girl’s life: SCP-106 has historically
found liquid barriers incredibly confusing,
and it’s been widely considered to be one
of the few ways to effectively delay the Old
Man’s rampages.
Seizing the moment, the Young Girl turned
and ran away.
The Water Nymph had just saved her life.
Sadly for them, neither the Water Nymph nor
the Young Girl escaped that day.
The Mobile Task Forces arrived and took control
of the facility again, recontaining the various
anomalies who had escaped.
But even if they never saw each other again,
the Water Nymph and the Young Girl would forever
remember how they helped each other on that
incredibly strange day.
Now go check out “SCP-053 - Young Girl”
and “SCP-054 - Water Nymph” for more of
today’s anomalies!